okay so we're going to be talking about
threats today guys because that's one of
one of the most common ways in which you
lose a game right there are two ways in
which you can lose a game one of them is
you blunder something you make a very
bad move and then your opponent
capitalizes on that and you lose the
game you've been doing a lot of those
and the second one is the second one the
second type of ways in which you can
lose is when your opponent actually
creates a trap he's threatening
something and you fail to see right you
fail to see you fail to defend against
it and then you're in big trouble so
we're going to be learning about a few
ways in which we can defend against
threats and one of them is capturing the
attacking piece okay so what is why
strap I think you already mentioned it
yes Luke 2h8 Bishop goes to f8 and then
yes the bishop the bishop has to retreat
with faith and then the Queen goes to d8
and that's checkmate right okay so how
can black defend against that he has a
few ways but he has a very good way
don't say it wait for me to ask ask
about you you already said it now I'm
going to give the opportunity to Arjun
Arjun go ahead
Quinn f2 absolutely the Queen goes to f2
how do we call this double attack fork
you can call it fork as well
I prefer double attack the rook the king
so you're going to be losing okay okay
this was the first way you can defend
against a trap and that is by capturing
or your opponent's piece your opponent's
attacking piece so how about this one
what is black strap I think you kind of
already know because of the arrow yes
Knight to e5 right Knight to e5 because
this point is pin that's how we call it
right okay so how can we defend against
that hmm there are a few ways to be
honest there is a few ways you can you
can defend against that threat what do
you guys think is the best one
sure you tell me
rook to f5 very nice very good yeah
that's actually probably the best move
in the position you're running and as
the second method run away with the
attacked piece with either of these two
pieces you could have run away you could
play kingi - that's another good move
but I think rucap five is actually the
best because it also attacks this pawn
right so very good so far so good
pretty easy what about this one
you tell me black strip and then you
tell me whites defense Arjun I know you
know I want new hands in the air how
about you not you you
what do you see unusual in this position
there's a there is a certain diagonal
which is very stacked with pieces how
about this one yeah
so you see you have one two three four
five pieces on one diagonal that's a lot
of pieces especially when there are two
bishops on it pieces with diagonal
action so what's black strap once again
sure Knight takes d5 absolutely that is
the threat so let's try to find ways in
which we can defend we had capturing the
attacking piece that was the first
method we had running away with the
attacked piece so now we're going to
have to be honest probably one of the
most common ways in which you can defend
a piece defend it how are you going to
do that look to see one interesting move
though not a very good move because
you're not defending your attacked piece
so now I'm going to be able to take the
knight take the pawn you take back my
knight I take back the bishop pawn up
yeah I have the advantage Black has the
advantage so let's try to find now
everybody knows nice how about you
very good work 2 D 1 absolutely this is
the best defense and to be honest
probably the only one well actually it's
not the only one and we will try to find
the other the other the other one as
well how about if 4 would be 4 be a good
move
yes exactly if you play E 4 this is not
the target anymore but the pawn on e4
becomes the target yeah so I'm just
going to take only 4 you're going to
take I'm going to take on b2 and that's
not game over but you lost the pawn
right sure
rugby 1 very nice exactly you're
defending the other attacked piece well
in the future potentially attacked piece
yeah the bishop on b2 this is what we
call prophylaxis in chess buddy a rugby
one is probably the best because the
rook is on on a 5 with much more squares
available so much better move ruled e1
okay good job we did three ways in which
we can defend against the threat so far
let's get to the next ones all right the
same the same scenario you're white you
tell me black strap which is to be
honest pretty obvious but you do have
more than one threat for black and then
you tell me a way in which you can
defend against it
our June if okay blacks black Stratus
Quinn takes that one absolutely
that's a checkmate okay let's try to
let's try to find a way we can defend
can we capture the opponent's attacking
piece no we'll get there we'll get there
we'll get there we'll get there give me
just one second
so can we run away why not it will
matter why can't we run away why can't
we play let's say Bishop to c4 checkmate
where I never mind I see so why can't
you just run away take the piece out of
harm's way
why yes you tell me to F where F 1 I
will just take the the Queen so maybe
something else
think about it and give me the whole
answer I don't want you to tell me one
move at a time I want you to tell me the
whole variation yes it has three moves
the whole variation has three moves
Bishop takes f1 rook takes f1 and that's
a checkmate yeah very nice so that's
another threat that you guys cannot miss
because if you do you get a check made
it so black forces the King in the
corner boxes him out in the corner and
then after Queen f2 yes we all see it
now absolutely so running away with the
piece not a good idea
can we defend the piece how
you have a lot of ways of defending the
peace yeah you can go with the Queen
only tool you can go with the Queen Oh
need one you can go with the rook on d1
you can go with the Queen on d3 you can
go with the Queen on c4 there's quite a
few ways actually you can also go with
the Queen on b1 if you want to be
technical about it so a lot of moves one
two three four five six moves yeah yes
Arjun mmm very interesting observation
yes why
let's take them one at a time
yes again the same problem we enough to
check first King boxes in the corner
Queen takes f1 Queen takes f1 row takes
f1 checkmate the same thing happens if
you put your Queen on b1 what about if
you put the Queen to d3 the same thing
yeah what about if you put the Queen on
e - you hang the rook yeah if you go
rook to d1 this is a little bit more I
would say a little bit more difficult to
to see but the same problem
Queen f2 King h1 Queen takes if one
takes a fun game over yeah so none of
those work now Arjen you keep quiet you
told me everything I needed to know
and all somebody else tries to give me
the correct answer what is the only way
to defend our Jun your hand down I'm not
going to take you unless somebody else
nobody else raises their hand yes
rook to f5 that's an interesting idea
but unfortunately if you put the rook to
a five I'm just going to take it
no I'm going to take it with the Queen
because I have the advantage and what do
we do when we have the advantage we try
to trade as many pieces as possible yeah
it's the fastest way to kind of increase
our advantage so we are taking with the
Queen you just gave away the rook for no
apparent reason
yes no no no my bad not you argent
somebody else you guys are on the right
track you have to interfere with his
attack this is the problem
so the fourth way of defending and yes
the threat is using interference
yes rook to d8 interesting how is that
now I'm not going to take with the rook
thank you very much I'm going to take
your bishop checkmate be careful again I
said interference and you play rogue d8
that's not a good not a good fit yes
very nice that's well that's pretty much
the only place you can place your queen
that's the only that's the only square
on this file using interference that
makes any sense if you play Queen f4 I'm
just going to take it right and she's
not defended another another interesting
aspect about Queen f3 is also that it
keeps contact with the rook
so you're still defending in the rook
you have the advantage you might as well
try to exchange the Queen's right Queen
takes f3 g takes f3
you got you got rid of all his threats
and now you're completely winning just
gonna take on a six game is over
very nice okay let's get to the last one
to the last way in which we can defend
against the trap
this one is a little bit trickier your
wife what is black thread and by the way
black has a few threats make sure you
tell me all of them when you're ready
you tell me one of them Arjun don't tell
me a move tell me what is black thread
Knight a5 you pick the difficult one
smart yes Knight a5 is one of one of
blacks threats because after you play
Knight a5 the Queen is actually trapped
right and the second threat which is
much more obvious than knight Knight a5
anybody can tell me Arjun hands down
I know you know it nope
yes nope I guess we have to ask Arjun
Arjun eat a xf3 thank you you just
capture a piece isn't that a clear
enough threat you trade a pawn for a
piece for a knife that's three points
for one it's not bad right
you're winning something so that's a
threat okay now that we found his
threats we have to find the defense as
well what can we do what are our options
in this position to defend against both
threats again one one of them was taking
the night that's the most obvious one
and the second one was to play Knight a5
with which traps the Queen so you have
to find a way there is only one way in
which you can defend against both of
them at the same time in one move
very good what is the point of this move
Knight g5 you're creating your own
threat at the same time how do we call
this when he's attacking us and we're
attacking back how do we call this
counter attacking yes so those are the
five ways in which you can defend
against the threat the first one was
capturing the second one was running
away the third one and probably most
most obvious one is defending the PCM
the fourth one interference
remember the interference from the
previous example and the fifth and the
last one the most difficult one the most
rare one counter attacking so yeah
that's that's it now you have weapons to
defend against threats
you